I heard you were a parrot's no that
wasn't the worst job I've ever had it
said that that was the worst job ever
no it seems worse I just I would just
want to hear about it Oh what parents
[Music]
welcome back to behind the screens a
weekly movies talk show with a new topic
each week and this week I'm so excited
with my guest Blake Jenner we're here to
talk about your movie a juvenile thanks
so much for coming thank you for having
me let's do a little catch up first how
have you been besides being the best
uncle ever
oh yeah well they're incredible meal I
just saw her like a few days ago and
she's just the best she's like I can't
wait till she can talk and we can
actually have conversations and hang out
I can throw some sunglasses on her and
take some dope little pictures together
looking like a little boy band covered
kind of thing but other than that yeah
just like kind of riding I'm riding
something new with a friend of mine I've
worked on that wrapped a movie a couple
months ago which I'm really proud of him
excited for that to come out it's called
American animals other than that kind of
just keep him busy yeah very very yeah I
know you were you were born and raised
in Miami so before we get going how our
friends and family doing back home they
are thankfully doing great the the storm
kind of like went off course a little
bit you know they got the outskirts of
it all but luckily you know they just
had some tree damage and some roof
damages but everybody's fine good to
hear it um so let's get into juvenile
because you just said you're just
writing you're writing something else
now but this is a film that you you
wrote and I believe was funded by
Kickstarter correct yeah yeah a portion
of it was funded by Kickstarter and then
a few other financed years that we had
talked to you saw like you know the
efforts that we made on Kickstarter the
video everybody that was excited about
it and gave funds to it and they kind of
came on board to finance the rest of it
so and now it's making its debut ad
Fantastic Fest which is going to be like
Vegas I think biggest growing festival I
mean there were more about it every year
I heard it's like the biggest genre Film
Festival in the u.s. so that's pretty
exciting I've never been
apparently super far like people fight
each other nice up in boxing too I've
done that I've been doing that for like
the past like five six months people are
fighting over there I'm gonna fight
that's the thing they do there all right
then I'm gonna find somebody I do
exclusive like Jenner's got
but how does it feel first of all like
how long has this journey been with this
film it's been a few years I think you
know like three three and a half you
know from riding and I started riding it
when I was when I was 20 and I was on
vacation and I kind of wrote the first
nine pages and I read it and I bounced
it off a couple people and I just
decided to keep going with it but it's
it's crazy now you know you ride it you
get it funded then you're like on set
and that's like the first moment where
you're like alright let me pinch myself
because this is insane
you see everybody that's cast and
they're perfectly cast for their roles
and then you see the first cut the
second cut third code is like the
directors putting it all together and
now that we're about to like have our
world premiere this is pretty insane
it's incredible - I'm so excited I'm so
proud of everybody involved I mean most
movies just don't get made so this you
have a background in like sketch comedy
and improv but this movie is like dark
and heavy what corner of your brain did
this come from this one
no I well I've always I've always you
know I've loved improv growing up and I
you know like Jim Carrey was my hero
growing up and and I was in love with
all of his like you know physical comedy
and just like the first movie I saw that
like made me want to be an actor was
Dumb and Dumber I was like oh that looks
like fun I can do that and got in there
like plays but I also had like a soft
spot for movies like this boy's life and
Good Will Hunting and Basketball Diaries
and stuff like that I grew up on those
as well
so when I was writing this I was kind of
coming from that corner of my heart you
know it just felt like that's a story
because I've written a few comedies like
comedic scripts up until that point I
was like well this is something I've
never really explored in myself and I've
always wanted to write a like a story of
like a like you know troubled youth with
all the potential in the world but he's
just you know the odds are against him I
wanted to tell that from my perspective
so I started writing this and I fell in
love I'm Eric I wanted to marry it and
see it through and yeah yeah it was just
a part of myself that I hadn't really
spoken from but I always knew it was
there so tell me about teaming up with
the director too because I know you guys
work together on Glee yeah Brad beaker
he's a man he's a man yeah yeah wasn't
when I was as I was writing this I would
tell everyone that I would
I would speak to about the script that
Brad was like the first guy that would
come to my mind so I'd have so much fun
working with him on Glee you know a lot
of the heavy stuff because my character
went through a lot of stuff who's like
dyslexic and went there on unrequited
love and all this stuff and I was always
with him that I would go through that
stuff so we white worked well together
and I really I knew he had like a vision
for editing and directing and all of all
of his stuff on Glee looks so beautiful
I sent him the script and when he
finally read it he we had like a meeting
I think we met for like a glass of wine
across the street from paramount where
we shot Glee and he said I'm in and he
talked about how much he loved it and we
both kind of saw eye-to-eye on how we
saw certain things and yeah we just hit
the ground running did you always write
it with the intention that you would
play Billy yeah yeah absolutely yeah
it's like it's such a departure for what
people know you from like Glee and edge
of 17 and everybody wants um it's a very
different character yeah no no this is
like a part of myself that I knew was
I'm there I was just like no I don't I
don't want to give this up to anybody
because even if I fall flat on my face I
want to be the one doing it I was like
I'm seeing this through is Billy for
sure well you don't fall flat on your
face but we're banking and for the
ladies there's a little side frontal I
want to do a little fill in the blank
with you because I read something
interesting about you online today it's
not bad the worst job I ever had was I
had to be ever probably kids your age I
have a copy kids oh yeah I heard you
were parents oh that wasn't the worst
job I ever had it said that those the
worst job ever
no I think it's worse I just I would
just want to hear about it Oh what
parents the parrot shop you just have
chops like they don't have it's not like
a well I've never heard a one before I
mean I know they sell parrots at like
Petsmart and stuff like that but there's
this plug it in a little bit there's
there's a store called the perfect
parrot on Riverside and Lankershim and
North Hollywood say go because the
people are great but yeah those are my
jobs with my odd jobs I had before
before I started on Glee and yeah it was
incredible you know it's like a little
shop you go in you kind of take the
birds out of the cage at the start of
the day you put them out on their stand
you're like feeding them there's like a
cool African gear it
African Grey called cowboy and he'd like
talk to him be like hey cowboy and you
give him like some Twizzlers at the head
in the front and stuff you could just
play with the birds you feed them and it
was normal it's like you're your average
kind of bird shot but it was cool I got
bit a few times
my first starter that was kind of like
scared you know this huge parrot that
they had her name was Matilda just like
a high synth I forget how to say it but
ya know it was a fun job that wasn't the
word the worst job I had I thought was I
have a crummy kids just because the they
would like spritz all the clothes in the
morning that's all you smell mm-hmm and
I would just have endless migraines
right you know the whole day and I'd go
home with him so I worked on I worked at
PacSun and they would do that well like
it was that bad no I loved that ya know
that's awesome but I know what you mean
I would spray yeah my last meal on death
row would be it would be salmon rice no
probably be like a trust me from sugar
fish oh yeah no that's what I usually do
now I go in there and like not as often
as I used to so I'm just like alright
yeah just just pile it on yeah yeah no
that would be that it would be that I
don't have it enough and if you're like
putting me on death row now and asking
me I'm like okay I'll revisit sugar fish
real quick I would do bottomless chips
and salsa because then that's like a
loophole cuz then they're just like are
you done you're like no no that's a good
that's a good yeah yeah well then you
pass out they kill you it's the one
movie I can watch every day and never
get sick of is it's kind of deep but my
friends give me crap about it whenever
they're coming over and I'm popping it
in and they're like again I love
Manchester by the sea Wow no it's okay
but I just love the acting in it I think
everybody in that movie is great and
it's got like a dark take on comedy that
I really appreciate but yeah that movie
it's at least a as of late yeah
my biggest turnoff is I think it's like
girls who make like pointless
like nickname slash like abbreviations
for words like I can't think of any
recognize like OMG - yeah yeah like
stuff like that like if you're gonna say
that like it's one thing to text it but
if you're saying it like that I'm just
like driving and drive me a little nuts
oh yeah GTG I'm currently stuck in my
head actually you know what I've been
listening to it's fun to run at that I
used to listen to oldies all growing up
but um stop the love you save and I want
you back by the Jackson 5 that's been on
my mind for a while nice yeah I mean not
to that oh that's like I mean I guess
it's never really gone away but I feel
like the Guardians stuff was just
revived it more yeah
my number one bucket for my number one
bucket my number one bucket list travel
destination is I really really want to
go to Japan one day I watched a
documentary a while ago with my with a
friend of mine it was called a hero
Dreams of Sushi mm-hm
and there's just one place where it's
like the waiting list is like 6 months
long but apparently it's the best sushi
you could have in the world I forget
what it is but it's like what it's
called but it's a it's like a restaurant
in the subway in the subway station and
in Japan I mean yeah that would be
incredible alright it's going to Japan
yeah one day that's what I got well
thanks so much for coming thank you so
much for graduations on this movie it's
fantastic and dark and you're gonna be
thinking about it for days weeks months
years thank you so much I'm excited yeah
so thanks thanks guys